alors sur ici radio canada.ca en nageant
savoir qu'ils demandent pourquoi les
noirs américains sont peu enclins à
penser à l'énergie solaire qu'on a dit
c'est une boule d'énergie qui est encore
disponible pour 5 milliards d'années et
qu en europe ça a été davantage
démocratise hic ici
alors j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus
l'énergie solaire la ccl l'énergie
probablement du futur on se le cachera
pas c'est une énergie qui est
extrêmement puissante à chaque demi
heure sur terre on reçoit autant
d'énergie que ce qu'on consomme dans une
année donc on n'est pas du tout rendu à
pouvoir récolter tout ça il va falloir
faire des efforts mais pourquoi en
amérique du nord je sais peut-être pas
je sais pas pour le reste du canada
il ya certainement une un aspect
technologie parce que les technologies
photovoltaïques
c'est un peu comme les voitures hybrides
ou voitures électriques cc des
technologies qui sont qui vont permettre
de créer une énergie ou une consommation
propre mais en arrière de tout ça il ya
des procédés qui sont très énergivores
qui sont très polluants fabriquer des
panneaux solaires ou disposer de
panneaux solaires c'est pas évident que
c'est que ses propres au québec on a on
est très très très choyé point de vue
énergétique on a fait le choix de
l'hydroélectricité il ya quelques
quelques dizaines d'années et ça c'est
une énergie qui rythment en propre ok et
kiki qui traite facilement disponible et
est en très grande quantité au québec
alors ça ça fait que le prix de
l'électricité le prix de ces énergies là
est très faible et son impact
environnemental aussi faible donc
vouloir faire le changement pour passer
des panneaux solaires sur notre maison
quand on paye en scène de kilowattheures
d'hydroélectricité il ya un aspect il ya
un aspect économique
il est même écologique n'est pas qui
n'est pas évident ces rémois qui sait
seul enjeu majeur c'est qu'en fait on a
l'impression qu'il ya des millions
d'euros québec sont souvent très très
contestée mais ce qu'on se rend pas
compte c'est qu'on paie l'électricité
vraiment pas cher puis se sache ça fera
pas changer les comportements
la même chose pour l'oim on est des
surconsommateurs de ces ressources là
qu'on a en abondance
si au québec donc tant qu'on paye repas
pour ça il y aura pas de changement vers
l'efficacité énergétique c'est
principalement pour ce oui il ya des
défauts au niveau technologique des
défis au niveau de la gestion des
déchets parce que des défis au niveau
des ressources qu'on parlait plutôt le
lithium et le cobalt ou ci intervient il
y en ad'autres le remède et des métaux
rares qui intervient dans la fabrication
des panneaux solaires
au delà de stuff c'est pourquoi qu'on
n'arrive pas à changer les habitudes
on paye plus cher si on compare à
comparer son comparer avec l'europe
représente peut-être pour miser sur la
voiture électrique et toutes les
technologies pour lesquels on reste
vraiment oui c'est nouveau pour moi je
vais je vais ramener encore ce que j'ai
dit un peu plus tôt mais la voiture
électrique oui oui mais faut faire
attention de prendre en compte tous les
ans parce qu'on risque de déplacer des
problèmes consommer plus d'électricité
et va générer plus de barrages et beau
faire en sorte que l'importation
exportation d'électricité va être des
balances et que ça va affecter tout le
reste globalement c'est pas juste au
niveau local pour garder soucis au
niveau global si on parle en termes de
gf qui sont globales et non locale je
peux rajouter un petit point là-dessus
poser les panneaux solaires sur une
maison vous acheter une voiture
électrique si en plus on peut être rendu
là dépendant tout dépendamment de notre
situation mais je dirais que c'est comme
le dernier geste à faire quand on ne
fait tout le reste avant de m'acheter ma
voiture électrique je vais peut être
essayer de voir qu'est ce que je
pourrais changer dans mon mode de
déplacement à ce que je peux pas me
rapprocher ce que je peux pas prendre le
transport en commun ce que je peux pas
habiter à côté de mon travail à ce que
je peux faire du télétravail à la place
si malgré toutes ces petites choses là
tout ces petits changements qui ne
vendent beaucoup moins d'énergie grise
dans le dans le domaine de l'analyse de
cycle de vie l'énergie grise si toute
l'énergie que on ne voit pas qui est
consommée par un objet ou par un choix
est ce que est ce que je peux changer
plein de petites choses pour ne pas
avoir à m'acheter un panneau panneaux
solaires est ce que je peux changer mais
ma consommation
ma façon de consommer mon électricité
dans ma maison en faisant attention si
je pose des panneaux solaires sur ma
maison mais que je fais pas attention de
fermer mes lumières quand je quitte ou
baisser le chauffage un peu la nuit ou
d'autres mesures très simples à faire et
ça aucun sens donc la même façon des
voitures électriques on récite
tout ce qu'on peut faire avant
d'utiliser la voiture électrique